not being able to do a push-up is the
rule and not the exception
and this is a problem for a number of
reasons it makes it very difficult to
perform
any other kind of exercise because you
see the thing is
anyone can perform a bench press all you
have to do is lower the weight enough if
you just
press the bar pretty much everyone can
do that and if you can't do that then
you can use a
lighter bar or even some really light
dumbbells with a push-up however
obviously first of all the lightest you
can go is about 70 of your body weight
but also you have the fact that this is
a more technical exercise
you need to brace your core in order to
keep your entire torso rigid
and the same goes for pull-ups and of
course a bunch of other functional
exercises
whether it's squats whether it's cleans
whether it's anything with a kettlebell
and if you try and force your way
through that stuff you might end up
getting injured the thing is though
these are the people that have the
most benefit from a functional program
if you can't brace your core if you
can't hold your body rigid and if you
can't move all your limbs with
coordination then this is going to mean
that you feel more awkward
more tired more stiff all throughout the
day at the same time
if you can't keep your core rigid
throughout a movement like the push-up
then you're also going to struggle when
it comes to
carrying something a long distance or
even getting out of bed in the morning
you might find that you're very stiff or
that you
put your back out so instead of just
trying to lose weight instead of just
trying to add muscle onto that kind of
wobbly frame
instead we should focus on just building
athleticism and this goes whether you
want to be
really massively strong and in shape or
whether you're just trying to be a
little bit healthier a little bit more
energetic and a little more mobile
but of course the problem is where do
you start if you can't do a push-up i do
have the batman begins program on the
website
and i do of course have the level zero
as part of my
super functional training program but
both of these still involve push-ups
and that very basic level of strength so
in this video i'm going to talk you
through some exercises you can do
to build stability coordination and core
strength
and to at the same time burn some fat
and tone some muscle and you don't need
any equipment you don't need any
experience and if you can't do a single
push-up or pull-up
that's absolutely fine for this beginner
functional workout we're going to be
taking a
mostly bodyweight calisthenics approach
you don't need any
sandbags any medicine balls battle rapes
anything like that all that stuff is
great but
a it can be tricky when you're starting
out and b if you don't have this stuff
then it's not going to be much use to
you everything we're going to do
involves just our own body weight and
that's actually perfect for building
functional strength and performance as
long as you're using it in the correct
way we can work on things like stability
on rotational strength on balance on
mobility and all these things going to
help to make us
injury free more energetic and better
movers so
there's really no excuse not to get
stuck in with functional training
because you literally
don't need any equipment we're also
going to be taking something of a
circuit approach
with limited rest times which will help
with metabolic conditioning basically
improving our work capacity so we don't
tire out as quickly that's one of the
big problems that a lot of people have
is that even if they've got the strength
throughout the day their core tires out
their legs tire out and that's when
accidents happen so building that
strength
over time and the ability to
continuously exert force is really
useful
at the same time building our work
capacity will let us train harder in
future
and at the same time it will of course
help us to burn calories especially
because we're combining
cardio higher up ranges faster movements
with a bit of resistance training
there are going to be harder and easier
variations for everyone along the way so
don't worry if there's anything that you
can't do
we'll deal with that as we come to it
i'm going to talk you through all the
movements show you how to do them
tell you how many sets and reps to do
but i'm not going to
do it all in real time for you to follow
along with i can do that in future if
that's something people would like to
see let me know in the comments down
below but
it'll be a very long video i think it'd
be quite boring more useful to just get
the information
and if you want to get the full program
written down then head over to my
website where you can find it
so many people struggle to do a push-up
or a pull-up but it might surprise you
to learn a lot of people
also struggle to do a sit-up and by the
way i just want to make absolutely clear
that that's absolutely fine like i say
it's normal
as we get older these things become more
difficult many of us have inactive
lifestyles or just so busy we don't have
time to train
and the way you sit all the time means
that you're so unfocused on your core or
moving your body in that way
that it's easy and normal to lose that
kind of control and you shouldn't feel
bad about it but the good news is that
you can get it back very very quickly
and that this
is the missing piece of the puzzle
that'll make all those other exercises
easier so yeah a lot of people struggle
to do sit-ups and they might find it
uncomfortable sitting on the ground
like their back digs in etc so we're
going to start this workout with an
alternative that anyone can do
what we need is a chair even a safe will
do sit on the edge and then just raise
the legs like this
and we're going to aim to do 30 likes so
and what this is doing is it's training
the core the abs
but in a way that doesn't require you to
be lying on the ground or
moving your body up which some people
also find hurts their backs
now the temptation with a movement like
this is going to be to
raise the legs using the hip flexors
more than the core so when you raise
your legs like this that's not actually
training the core at all it's training
the legs
what you have to do is to try and get
just a little bit of a crunch
at the top if you can by curling it up
now like i say we're going to be trying
to do
30 sets of those and if you can't do the
full 30
then just take a short time out keep it
as brief as possible and carry on
or you can make it easier by raising
just one leg making sure to do
the same thing on both sides keep the
other one off the ground a little bit if
you can
and if you find it too easy conversely
you can make a bit harder
by lifting something like a medicine
ball or even just
you know a book or a backpack with a few
things in it
up towards your chest by clenching it in
between your feet and pulling up like
that
so we're starting off with 30 of those
completed as quickly as possible
there's going to be a 30 second rest
time then we're gonna move on
to the next exercise okay next up is air
squats absolutely classic movement
everybody knows how to squat
or at least everyone should know again a
lot of people can't get into a resting
squat position and that's simply through
sitting so much which gives you those
tight hip flexors and can lead to all
sorts of problems such as an anterior
pelvic tilt we want to get the mobility
back this way at the same time going to
build some strength in the legs
but don't worry to begin with if you
can't squat all the way down into a deep
squat
atg asta grass it's absolutely fine just
to go down as far as you can
and back up try and keep the back
straight
as you do this try and sit straight down
feet slightly shoulder width apart just
do what you're comfortable with and if
that means going just to 90 degrees
then hey that's absolutely fine as well
we're so used to hearing that we need to
push
ourselves as much as possible you know
no pain no gain this kind of idea
in order to get a response but the truth
is that to begin with what's most
important is just enjoying it
getting used to those movement patterns
and not pushing yourself too hard
because
it's counterproductive at the end of the
day so do what you can
aim to make this a regular thing and by
the way recommend you do this workout
about three times
a week again you may find that 30 squats
in a row is a little bit
too hard or too easy if it's too hard
then a easy variation you can use
is to hold on to something and then to
use your hands to slightly help
raise yourself each time if it's too
easy
then try holding a weight in front of
you such as a light kettlebell
this is perfect because it trains
anti-flexion meaning that you
can't bend your body forwards this is
the same trait you need anytime you pick
up something heavy if you want to avoid
hurting your back or falling on your
face so it's a handy thing to have
okay next up we're doing high knees
which just look like this like you're
running on the spot
and we're going to do 30 on each side of
these and what these are doing you once
again train the hip flexors to an extent
because you're bringing up those legs
just as you do
when running but at the same time the
aim is to bring yourself to a nice
steady balance after each one of these
and what that's going to do
is to improve your hip stability and the
reason that's important is because when
you start running long distances in
particular
it can help to prevent an injury what
you can do instead
if there's any risk of hurting yourself
doing that to begin with is to just
place the foot down and bring it up and
focus on balancing
and this will very quickly get you
sturdier and more stable on your feet
this is also a good chance to record
yourself and watch yourself back and to
look at how you're performing
if you notice yourself wiggling more on
one side than the other then that might
point to some kind of weakness
likewise if you notice that you have
valgus knees or if you're feeling the
pressure more on the inside of your foot
this can all be useful information to
take to a coach or to a physiotherapist
to improve your posture your technique
and to thereby further reduce the
chances of injury
and of course if you can't do that then
you can just hold on to something to
help yourself balance as you
raise and lower the leg again we're
aiming for 30 on each side
and next up is punches what we're going
to do with these punches is try and
put our hips into them slightly just
slightly rotating the body
as we punch we want to go nice and sharp
and crisp
this is actually something you need to
work on for the whole thing because it's
so much better
to do push-ups that are sharp and
powerful
but just a few of them than it is to do
lots of really slow awkward ones we're
trying to become more explosive here
more athletic
which is going to help us through all
the other exercises we do but the real
reason i like these punches i put them
in here
it's because they just include a very
slight rotational element
which is something that's missing from
so many workouts and it's very slight
but it's enough to just get the
obliques slightly involved and that's
something that you can build on in
future
as you start to progress further in your
functional training oh hello there so
i'm in this compromising position
ready to show you bird dog so this is an
exercise where
you're on all fours and you lift one arm
and the opposite leg at the same time
stretch them out ahead of you this will
work your mobility at the same time it
builds coordination because it's a
contralateral movement
using your right arm the same time as
your left leg it also is very good for
the corn in particular the multifidus
muscles which are the very small muscles
that run up the spine
and their job they're rich in muscle
spindles those are sensors that detect
and predict movement
and what they do is they prepare for
movement so if you're stepping down a
step
it's the multifidus muscle that gets you
ready gets you braced for that
slight drop that you're expecting this
is a really good thing to
train if you want to prevent injury and
at the same time improve your
ability to move healthily and
impressively the key here then
is not to perform this quickly but to
hold
each position for a couple of seconds
get the arm out nice and straight in the
leg
and this time we're just going to do 10
on each side and it's a bit of a nice
break
push up is a difficult one like i say a
lot of people can't brace their core
throughout them
let alone muster enough peck strength to
push themselves up
this makes it difficult to do enough
volume to trigger the kind of response
we want so the solution
is to do the incline push-up which i
think is even easier than doing it on
the knees
if you're still learning and the great
thing is it's extremely adaptable
so what you're going to do is you're
going to grab a chair a bed a bench
anything you like put your hands on it
and then just perform a push-up
like so from there again it's important
to keep your core as straight as
possible so you want your body to be in
a nice straight line
and then you're going to try and perform
30 of those in a row again
with a minimum rest in between
and once again if it's too easy then all
you need to do
is lower the height and if it's too
difficult
increase the height and to do that you
can push yourself up against a wall even
so
barely any weight on there at all but
just practicing that movement and
practicing
keeping the core nice and straight and
then we're doing skater hops and all
you're going to do for this is jump from
side to side
tap behind jump to one side to tap
behind so you're landing on the outside
leg and then the inside one is coming
across
and tapping behind that one and the
reason this is useful
first of all this is a movement in the
frontal plane the frontal plane meaning
side to side
as opposed to the sagittal plane meaning
forwards and back or up and down
that's missing in so many workouts
especially beginner programs
and it's something again that we have to
do all the time just like that rotation
so we want it
in there in some form to build that
stable base
and at the same time it teaches more
coordination it's very basic movement
and if you can perform that it's going
to help you with all kinds of other
things
that you can add onto later on down the
road
so i said you didn't need any specialist
equipment and then here i am hanging
from a rope but bear with me
because this same exercise can be
performed with any kind of setup
whether it's a towel draped over pull up
bar whether it's a towel draped around a
door handle or whether it's a towel
draped around a bed
so a towel but to be honest you can also
use a bed sheet
or just literally anything you can hang
from and pull yourself from trees are
great
and basically what we're going to be
doing here is a bodyweight row so you're
going to hang on to the rope
lean backwards and then you're going to
pull yourself up and down
as you go and again the further back you
lean the more difficult it will be and
the more upright you are the easier it
is so it's really adaptable to any
difficulty level
this is a perfect exercise because it's
the perfect counter
to the push-up so whereas the push-up is
an anti-extension movement this is an
anti-flexion movement you're
practicing keeping your body in that
rigid position but now it's when there's
something pulling on the front of you
very similar to when we were doing the
squats but holding something light in
front of us
and this is also a pulling movement
which we really need to balance out all
of those pushing movements many
beginner workouts only include pushing
movements anything that's entirely on
the ground is gonna have a hard time
challenging those pulling movements
which can lead to an imbalance where
you're hunched over because all of your
front muscles are pulling you forwards
and you haven't built those back muscles
to pull you
back again seeing as we're hunched over
anyways at the desk which causes
kyphosis and other issues
that's not ideal that said if you don't
have access to a pull-up bar or a tree
or a rope or a
bed then don't worry about it too much
because we are just starting out
and trying to write the perfectly
balanced program can actually end up
standing in the way of progress
just get doing something and then work
on improving those missing areas later
on
if you have to admit this exercise it's
not the end of the world
next up we're going to do some plank and
plank is something that's very
misunderstood by a lot of people
there's been a lot of narrative on the
web at the moment about plank being
useless and not particularly helpful
because we already
spend so long in a anti-extension
position
and because it's not that challenging
etc etc but actually for someone who
really lacks the core strength necessary
just to keep their body rigid
this is a really good way to build up
that basic strength there that's going
to help to perform better quality
push-ups
and all kinds of other exercises at the
same time it can help to prevent injury
because there's the endurance aspect to
it again it's about not just being
strong enough in the core
but being able to maintain that strength
throughout a busy tiring day
and still not injure yourself so
beforehand
all you're going to do put your arms on
the floor
and hold your body like so the most
important thing is that you're
braced in the core and that means that
your waist isn't sagging like that
it needs to be in the nice straight line
position and that's what we're working
on
you can hold this for 30 seconds to
begin with that's absolutely fantastic
if that's too easy to get up to a minute
if it's too hard drop onto your knees
and still try and hold that same
position
for 30 seconds and this is what i'm
going to share a really useful tip for
all of these exercises and that's
the mechanical drop set if you can do
something but you can't do it
to the volume or for the duration that
i'm prescribing here
then what you need to do is perform the
most difficult version for as long as
you can
then switch immediately to the easier
version so for instance
if you can do plank for 10 seconds but
you can't do it for 20 seconds or 30
seconds
and all you need to do is to get into
that position to start with
and as soon as that starts getting
tiring just drop your knees and continue
you can do the exact same thing with the
squats for instance if you can do squats
with a light kettlebell
perform those for as long as you can and
as soon as that becomes difficult throw
the
kettlebell to one side and carry on
performing those squats
and gradually you'll do more and more of
the difficult ones and fewer and fewer
of the easy ones mechanical drop sets
massively underutilized tool
that are fantastic for all kinds of
things essentially lets you
train max strength and control but at
the same time to go for those higher rep
ranges
that trigger hypertrophy and improved
endurance so it's the best of both
worlds
and this is a circuit meaning that we're
going to complete the entire thing a
total of three times that's the aim
you can just do twice to begin with
that's absolutely fine 30 second break
between each exercise and one minute
break
in between each lap of the circuit or
two if you really need it
so you found that useful interesting
guys if you did then please leave a like
and share around that helps me out
immensely
hit the subscribe button for more like
this and the bell button if you want to
be notified when i post new videos
if you like functional training and you
want to learn more about it then you
probably know already that i have a new
book out called functional training
and beyond which released very recently
in
the us and will be releasing soon across
europe and the rest of the world
please check out the description down
below i massively appreciate all your
support so far
guys the comments on facebook were so
like
just generous and kind and i couldn't
believe the response i got with so many
people entering the contest
three people have now been selected to
win the signed copy
so stay tuned i'll be in touch and we'll
get those sent out to you
as soon as possible to everyone else
thank you so much for entering again
thank you so much for the support
i appreciate it more than you know i
think i have the the best community on
youtube but i'm sure everyone says that
but
i think it might actually be true in my
case i'm extremely lucky
um so yeah thanks for watching this one
thanks for all the support
up until now and stay tuned for more
coming very soon
thanks time for watching and bye for now